you just [ __ ] sabotaged me there you
got your audi did i go to the audi guy
and [ __ ] you up oh you know what you've
been driving my audi more than me
okay good
because your niece is has my car she has
to go to college that's the problem
right is because the reason for the new
car is right and so uh jules just is
just gone and she takes the car wow all
day an adult
but i think that we should have her buy
the car from us but you don't believe in
that
no
because because i'll tell you why jules
is like my daughter
i don't have any kids
so all my like
fatherly instincts go to her and when i
was a kid my parents got me anything i
wanted
so keep that
i do that too
yeah wait is that scary because yeah no
because here's the deal dude i don't
want spoiled little [ __ ] you won't you
won't because we're gonna if we have
kids you're gonna be the mother and then
they're out of the way
she's our kids are [ __ ] they're all
going to have mta bus passes and that's
a fact yeah
but they're also going to have audi's in
the garages for the weekend just for the
just for the weekend yeah yeah okay i'm
going to give them like you gotta like
you have to learn a little bit of grit
sweetie you can't just when i was seven
everything when i was 17 years old i
went to rehab
and
when i left the rehab
i go well since i went to rehab can you
send me to hawaii with my friends nice
and my parents my parents were like oh
i go it's going to be good because i i
believe in god and i think
you know when i'm out in nature you know
i mean i kind of manipulated it and they
they
bought it wow they bought it you know
what i mean so that's my point
and look at me now
i came out he came out okay he's eating
an evoke i'm getting it i'm getting the
vote or you know i mean m6
at bmw
what's the matter tongue-tied
shocked attack
what
i mean look
that's how you want to raise children
that's fine
no listen very good there's other skill
sets that i have
right i can teach them how to do time
oh
yeah that's true i just learned that
that's fresh right i can teach them
about um
i'll teach them about more pop culture
kind of stuff
yeah and you can do mathematics and
biology whatever you need i can do that
yeah yeah uh history i know some history
you know um but you're like if if the
little girl is like dad i want a pony
you're gonna give her the pony at like
eight years old i'm not gonna buy a
while rent one
oh what joe rogan runs ponies he does i
assume he's got kids guys i assume
or llamas i know dude i know dudes that
do llama well yeah if you bring over you
like rent the little farm right i mean
for their birthday like sebastian
his kids he has mario lopez come over
why can't i
right yeah mario yeah yeah i'm going to
run a mario lopez right it's not that
bad yeah yeah
right
maria munoz those types they'll come
over to the house
right and they can do like
extra extra
[Laughter]
what celebrity could you pull uh for
your daughter at this point in my career
yeah or who do you think you will
actually know and
well i could probably get keegan
who's that yeah keegan keys i would show
her pekim peel oh yeah you prep her with
stuff yeah yeah she cause she's gonna
like what i like so it's like she's
gonna like the pixies so i'll have joyce
santiago come over
right i'm gonna i'm gonna let her i'm
gonna she's gonna fall in love with the
think people that i know
you want to see modern family yeah then
eric stones you know i mean i'm not
gonna show her [ __ ] mission
impossible i don't know tom cruise yeah
right that's smart right yeah why do you
keep making me watch bill burr
yeah so dad is gonna be the hero then
dad knows all the cool people all the
cool people right and mom's
she's disciplined
she's no fun
i have a feeling you're actually gonna
be the disciplinarian
yeah you rage out a lot quicker your
patience is very
you have what we call short bull
yeah but i wouldn't
no violence
i yeah no violence no violence i'm not
violent at all number two
i would be pretty mindful about it
because i remember it [ __ ] me up as a
kid
so i don't know i don't think so i think
you're wrong and i want you to apologize
i'm sorry all right um
but i would probably um
like if my kid do something as a kid
talk back to me
[ __ ]
um can we turn it down a bit
[Laughter]
caught me
that's what i'd say yeah interesting all
right i would back away
right how many steps how many steps
about 100 steps
yeah i'll go interesting walk backwards
he'd make a molotov cocktail i know
yeah i'd have a bottle of like whiskey
right i put some [ __ ] cloth in it
laid it on fire and throw it no i would
back away interesting and i would go
outside and i would probably call my
sponsor
oh
interesting and good yeah my
yeah mike one of my kids
[Laughter]
and then you'd be like well how old is
she
four she can't even speak yet uh well
who taught her that language
kalylah no oh it could have only come
from you no
i don't say that word you just said i
haven't said that word in years you said
it yeah but that's me in the context of
being a child
character character yeah
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy you guys
relationships take work right can we all
agree with that i agree a lot of us will
drop anything to go help someone we care
about right but we'll go out of our way
to treat other people well but often do
we give ourselves the same